[Music]
on this thursday night replacing
quarantines with rapid tests
it's about knowing that you're safe
before you get on the first of its kind
pilot project about to take off at a
canadian airport
a trend quebec is desperate to reverse
we need to do
something as bc and alberta set records
again
turmoil in nigeria over police brutality
we can just continue
the street process the escalating chaos
and violence and american election
predictions how pollsters got it wrong
in 2016 and why they're more confident
this time
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a tentative move being made
that could lead to the end of the 14-day
quarantine period for travelers coming
into canada
the federal and alberta governments are
launching a pilot project
being tested in alberta that will allow
canadians returning to the country
to take a covid19 test on arrival if
they test
negative they will not need to
quarantine though they will need to have
a second test six to seven days later
alberta's premier who himself is
self-isolating because one of his
ministers has tested positive
says it's time to return to normal safe
travel
and the airlines agree redmond shannon
has our top story tonight
it's a day westjet's ceo has waited
eight
months for it's not an overstatement to
say that today's announcement
is actually the first piece of good news
we have received as an airline
since february the 29th when i sat on a
sunday afternoon
watching our bookings get outstripped by
cancellations
alberta premier jason kenny believes
this new testing plan will help get the
province's economy moving again
we cannot turn our back on the travel
industry
the tourism industry and the albertans
whose lives
have been thrown into upheaval as a
result of the pandemic
starting november 2nd people arriving
into alberta from abroad can voluntarily
take a covet 19 test at calgary airport
or the main u.s land crossing they must
then proceed into a 14-day quarantine
as before if the test comes back
negative
they can leave quarantine however they
must provide a second test on day
six or seven and must not visit high
risk
settings in that two weeks alberta is
also rolling out advanced pre-departure
tests for people who plan to travel
abroad on
tuesday europe's busiest hub of london
heathrow
introduced a rapid one-hour coveted test
for people
flying to hong kong it's about knowing
that you're safe before you get on
otherwise if you land
in the destination country and you did
test negative
then you'll be put into an isolation
this could all inform the future of air
travel
toronto's pearson airport is
investigating the use of rapid
pre-departure tests
too and trials tests for arriving
passengers
last month but some experts say testing
everyone
especially people coming from low
infection countries
is a waste of precious resources now we
have lots of community transmission
that is local and homegrown so allowing
another travel case
into the mix may be a drop in the bucket
relative to what's actually going on in
a given location
the program at calgary's airport could
soon expand to edmonton
with canada's other international hubs
watching closely too
redmond shannon global news and we are
watching the kovid 19 numbers in canada
tonight again there are signs case
numbers are on the rise
spreading through some communities too
quickly to effectively contact trace
there were more than one thousand new
cases reported in quebec today and 20
people there died
the premier said to reduce close contact
all quebecers who can work from home
should now do that at this time
we need to reduce even the risk of
contact because
we cannot afford to continue having
about a thousand new cases every day
so we need to do something
and the virus is now beginning to spread
faster in western provinces which had
low numbers over the summer
if you look at the number of active
cases per capita across canada right now
manitoba leads the country with 130
active cases per capita quebec is second
with 105.
alberta has 77 active cases per capita
and ontario
43. a second wave of covid19 has hit
british columbia too
274 new cases were reported there today
the highest ever in that province
alberta also set a new record 427 new
cases
there today one of the other indicators
to keep an eye on is the positivity rate
the percentage of tests that are coming
back positive
the higher the number the more
concerning it is
mike drollay explains alberta's surge of
new covet 19 cases is not
slowing daily case records are being
broken for all its testing 2.5 percent
came back
positive for the virus its highest
number since early may
but premiere jason kenny himself in
isolation after one of his cabinet
ministers tested positive
remains bullish on a plan to boost
alberta's economy
i invoked the the british slogan that
during the blitz keep calm and carry on
we cannot shut down
our lives and and our twin goal here is
protecting both lives and
livelihoods kova 19 numbers may be
rising
but he says alberta has suffered enough
economically
with the energy price collapse it tells
me
that not everyone's on the same page and
it tells me that
public health stratagem is heavily
politicized
and i understand why that happens every
province is looking at the data
one of the most effective is positivity
rate with 2.2 percent of all tests in
canada
coming back as positive since the start
of the pandemic
but recent data reveals not all regions
with high daily case numbers are
experiencing the pandemic equally
bc broke a daily case record wednesday
but its positivity rate is only 1.7
percent
alberta is 2.5 percent in manitoba that
rate is nearly double at 4.8 percent
just behind quebec at 5 and while
ontario is right on the average at 2.2
percent
toronto's 4.4 percent is considered to
be in the high alert range for
jurisdictions
it's concerning for all of us but we're
looking to see what
action the measures that we put in place
are going to have looking ahead
epidemiologists worry of virus fatigue
especially with higher positivity
numbers expected
we knew we were going to have a hard
fall and probably a hard winter
we knew this was coming the question now
is how we're all going to deal with it
mike turley global news toronto there
were more than 800 new cases reported in
ontario today and there are more
outbreaks of covenant 19 in hospitals
there an outbreak has been declared at
scarborough general hospital six
patients have tested positive in one
unit
at the toronto rehabilitation
institute's university center site four
patients
have covid19 there are outbreaks as well
at st
michael's hospital saint joseph's health
center toronto western hospital and the
center for addiction and mental health
all the facilities say they've taken
steps to contain the spread including
more rigorous cleaning and increased
testing of patients
and staff it is the deadliest day of the
pandemic in manitoba four more people
have died of covid 19 there and
147 new cases were reported community
spread is a problem and so beginning on
monday new restrictions will go into
effect in the northern health region and
churchill
the new rules will be the same as those
in place in winnipeg including
gatherings limited to five people
casinos and entertainment facilities
closed and lower occupancy limits for a
number of businesses
all schools in the north and in winnipeg
will have tighter restrictions imposed
as they're elevated to the orange alert
level
there is an outbreak at manitoba's
largest poultry plant accelador in
blumenthal at south of winnipeg
27 people there have tested positive for
covid19 and one employee
has died the provincial government says
there's no evidence the virus is
spreading between
employees within the plant itself and
that the cases appear to be the result
of community transmission
in ottawa the prospect of a snap federal
election is off the table for now but
the opposition is continuing to push for
answers from the government
about its handling of the pandemic it
wants a committee form that would have
sweeping powers to call cabinet
ministers as witnesses and
force the government to hand over
thousands of documents
the liberals say the motion is so broad
it would paralyze their handling of a
second wave of the pandemic
mike likature explains i think the
member opposite is right that when we
work together
canadians appreciate it and our response
is stronger what a difference a day
makes
24 hours after daring opposition parties
to trigger an election
the government was preaching cooperation
in the house of commons
but the latest conservative motion is
calling for a full review
of the government's response to the
first wave of the pandemic
including the rollout of rapid tests and
the procurement of protective equipment
so we can prepare
better for the second and possibly
future waves of covid19 that is what
this motion will accomplish liberal
sources say disclosing contract
information could affect the
government's ability
to negotiate future deals for things
like vaccines or
ppe health officials would have 15 days
to produce
all documents which the government
argues is too tight of a timeline for
the mountain of work
the government is willing to work with
the opposition to come up with the
timeline that is reasonable
that sense of collaboration in
parliament also had a hint of
condemnation
with the leader of the black quebecois
telling the liberals
to stop threatening votes of
non-confidence they take all the
businesses who need
help in canada and they stick a knife
under their truth and they tell the
black quebecois and the quebecers and
the canadians and the conservatives
do what we say a one government source
tells global news they don't want a
repeat
of wednesday's political drama but the
reality is
that threat will remain as long as we
have a minority government
donna okay mike look at her in ottawa
thank you
people on a first nation in northern
ontario are facing a huge upheaval in
their lives because of a worsening water
crisis
hundreds of people have had to leave
their homes on the nescanaga first
nation
the remote community is about kilometers
northeast of thunder bay it's only
accessible by air or
by ice road in the winter for 25 years
that community has been
under a boil water advisory and this
month it got worse
an oily sheen was spotted in the water
reservoir and the treatment plant had to
shut down
there is no longer any running water at
all in the community
residents have been airlifted to thunder
bay the chief says they will not return
until it is safe you hate to see uh
your uh relatives your children your
future
living in this condition and there seems
to be no end
it's one problem after another and
everything we get is just a band-aid
solution
the water testing and repairs are
expected to take weeks
today the deputy prime minister was
asked about the crisis christiere
freeland repeated a promise the
government has made before
that the liberal government is committed
to ensuring all communities in canada
have
safe drinking water in northern colorado
hundreds of people have been ordered to
leave their homes because of a
fast-moving
wildfire this is the east
troublesome fire it's tearing through an
area packed with homes cabins and
businesses
it's burning around 2 000 hectares every
hour
towering flames are being fueled by
strong winds the public is being warned
there could be widespread destruction
the fire has burned 50 000 hectares so
far and is already the fourth largest
in colorado's history round
two coming up donald trump and joe biden
prepare to face off on the big stage
in the second presidential debate
turning to the u.s now if you missed the
last presidential debate
you get a second chance tonight
president donald trump and his
democratic rival joe biden will be back
on stage
trump did so much interrupting in the
last debate it was widely panned as
pointless and frustrating organizers of
this one are hoping new rules will help
keep things under control but it
is 2020 and as jackson proskow reports
anything
is possible divided by plexiglas
and politics the final debate between
joe biden and donald trump is perhaps
the last chance to redefine the race
it's not just convincing the undecided
it's also
changing the minds of people who've
already committed to joe biden
so right now the president has the most
to lose this late in the game the second
round matchup is likely more show than
substance more than 40 million americans
have already voted
the number of undecided voters is
dwindling
while biden is polling consistently
ahead in key swing states
joe biden is in the driver's seat he's
doing really really well
there is only one america biden is
spending big on tv ads airing during the
world series
there is so much we can do if we choose
to take on
problems and not each other trump's
campaign is pulling ads in key states
and has fallen behind on fundraising the
president's last ditch attempt to
launder unproven allegations against
biden and his son hunter
hasn't moved the needle i wish you would
interview joe biden like you interviewed
me
though he's running against biden trump
spent the day on the attack against
the press releasing his own recording of
his upcoming interview with 60 minutes
featuring a lengthy airing of grievances
well then you brought up a lot of
subjects that
were inappropriately brought up
questions they were inappropriately
all of it suggests trump has no plan to
change his message track now
despite the fact that the same polls
that put biden ahead
suggest americans are deeply concerned
with real issues
like the pandemic that has killed 220
000
or the economy that has left 10 million
unemployed
things can always change but the
incumbent president faces a difficult
road to election day
jackson the last debate was well you
know it was hard to watch
they're trying something new tonight
right they are donna to make sure that
people at home can understand the
candidates and what they stand for
the start of each of the six segment
topics will give each candidate two
uninterrupted minutes to make their
point
and to make sure they're uninterrupted
they're going to mute the opposing
candidates microphone
donna that doesn't guarantee that any
shouting won't be picked up by the other
mic
but it should certainly make it easier
for people at home to understand what
the candidates are actually saying
okay to quote the president we'll see
jackson in washington thanks
still ahead the president of nigeria
responds to violent anti-police protests
nigeria's president is appealing for
calm as violent anti-police protests
continue there looting and gunfire broke
out
in nigeria's largest city today anger is
building since the shooting deaths
of civilians by security forces this
week the government denies it happens
a curfew is in place in lagos and
several other states but as crystal
gomencing reports
it isn't working a smoldering
supermarket
shoppers running to safety after looters
set this fire in legos flames
rising from a jail the military called
in to deal
with a riot inside just two examples in
a series of sometimes
violent protests across nigeria
people have taken to the streets calling
out police brutality
allegations of beatings and corruption
your voice has been heard loud
and clear and we are responding
nigeria's president muhammadu buhari
called for the demonstrations to end but
he did not
address reports that protesters have
been
killed and i can't give you the actual
number of casualties because
i'm not good i have to run for my life
amnesty international confirmed through
witness interviews videos and hospital
reports
that at least 12 peaceful protesters
were killed by authorities
at two protest locations in lagos
the demonstrations began two weeks ago
after a video was shared
it appeared to show the killing of an
unarmed man by members of the special
anti-robbery squad officials have called
it fake
kennedy leo lives in canada but has
family
in nigeria he says more people are
joining the protests in nigeria as they
see
demonstrations being shut down and
people beaten
and violently arrested by police now the
violence is getting closer to the middle
class it's healing
dissent the industrial side of lagos the
tech side of lakes it's hitting areas
like leki where you see opera nigerian
youth and middle class who are also now
see themselves as victims of those
violence canada and britain have
expressed concern
over reports of excessive use of force
it's a complex situation but
canada is always i we hope a firm
believer in human rights
and protecting human rights nigeria's
president however says foreign
governments
should not pass judgment without all the
facts
crystal gomencing global news london
trusting the u.s posters what went wrong
in 2016
and what's different this time
every american election is important but
time magazine wanted to make a point
about this one so it changed the cover
of its november 2nd edition
the word time is replaced with the word
vote times editor-in-chief says we stand
at a rare moment one that will separate
history
into before and after for generations
it does feel like there is a great deal
at stake and every four years pollsters
get busy trying to gauge the mood of
america
in 2016 almost all of them got it wrong
tonight eric sorenson has a flashback to
the days leading up to that election
and looks at what pollsters are doing
differently this time
cnn now projects that donald trump will
carry the state of wisconsin
in 2016 the u.s networks were as stunned
as the campaigns themselves
this is a state that hillary clinton
hasn't even visited
hillary clinton didn't go to must win
wisconsin in the final weeks because she
and everyone else
believed the polls the final polling
average gave clinton a six point lead in
that state
on election day trump won by about one
point
wisconsin may have been the biggest miss
but it wasn't the only one that puzzled
experts
mike murphy what did you miss oh boy i
missed a lot
what eluded pollsters in 2016 in part
undecideds broke strongly for trump
instead of the usual
50 50. a lot of third party support
flipped in the end to trump
and some polling didn't give enough
weight to less educated voters
that voting group doesn't respond as
readily to pollsters
but they still voted and mostly for
trump that's a lot of like
soul-searching
after 2016 the polling industry has put
a lot of resources into it for 2020
the industry has really focused on
ensuring that
the polls are robust pollsters are once
again confident
this year because the data have been
more consistent four years ago the
polling averages
showed hillary clinton in blue and
donald trump in red were often neck and
neck through 2016
and it was volatile clinton would surge
ahead and trump would close the gap
and it was like that all the way to
election day 2020 is different
joe biden in blue started in january
with about a six point lead
and the polling averages have kept that
lead all the way through the year there
has been remarkably
little volatility this year and biden
still has about a seven to eight point
lead
the odds are definitely against trump he
has a path to victory
it's just that it's much narrower than
joe biden's
to get an accurate snapshot pollsters
continually rebalance data by age
gender race even education this is why
all the posters are working on a likely
voter model
where they try to estimate
what will be the composition of the
electorate but the polls can't always
capture though
is the enthusiasm the turnout democrats
know that
we can't be complacent i don't care
about the polls
there were a whole bunch of polls last
time didn't work out
and so in wisconsin democrats are
getting out a huge early vote
what's driving them to come out what
isn't everything is driving me here
today
if the polls do miss this time it could
be the other way
by underestimating the democrats
motivation to vote in 2020.
eric sorensen global news
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the cenotaph in stratford
ontario
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Applause]
[Music]